i think we have enough of an interview  here hope okay that's enough let's go  this russian bounty story we have  multiple sources saying  that trump knew all along i was there  for a tiny little short period of time  it was much more for an inspection there  was no problem during the day and said  quote  crazy joe biden he doesn't know me but  he would go down fast and hard crying  all the way they'll go out and they'll  vote and they're gonna have to go and  check their vote by going to the poll  and voting that way people are flushing  toilets 10 times 15 times  as opposed to once the state department  is emphasizing to world leaders that  they should stay at donald trump's  hotels and they say the noise causes  cancer you tell me that one okay rare  trump ordered robert mueller the special  prosecutor be fired the factory policy  is wear a mask at all times and trump  puts on goggles but no mask